hey guys today we're going to talk about
mushrooms do you like mushrooms comment
below if you like them I love mushrooms
but mushrooms are not a plant they're
not a vegetable they're actually a
fungus okay and it's a myth
that consuming of fungus will give you a
fungus that's not how it works normally
in our gastrointestinal tract we have
friendly funguses we have friendly yeast
we have friendly bacteria that counter
the unfriendly and so when you lose
those microbes your body can then grow
and have an overgrowth of fungus on the
toenail and different parts of your body
but you're not going to actually have to
worry about getting a fungus if you eat
mushrooms okay there are certain types
of we can't call them phytonutrients
plant-based nutrients anymore we have to
call them maybe of fungus nutrients
there's certain nutrients that are
really good for various things
inflammation anti-cancer and insulin
resistance beta glucans great for
insulin resistance which is exactly what
we're trying to do when we do keto and
in and fasting so anti-cancer properties
with different types of mushrooms did
you realize that there's more potassium
in one cup of mushrooms than there is in
one banana 350 milligrams about three
grams of protein I mean not really high
not too low in one cup there's two carbs
okay but don't worry about it turning
into sugar very fast because it's not
going to it's a very global glycemic
food B to lots of item B to bottom B 3
and B 5 which is exactly what you need
to do when you go through keto
adaptation that's when you need to prove
that keto fatigue vitamin D which is
fascinating choline which is good for
the liver of fatty liver it's it's a
type of B vitamin that strips off fat
from the liver and helps build up
certain types of chemicals in the body
for concentration focus and like brain
energy iron and selenium which is also
really good for the liver good for the
thyroid and good as an anti-cancer so
definitely start consuming more
mushrooms and your diet
add some
garlic and onion saute them okay thanks
for watching so we've been getting a lot
of success stories but I don't have your
success story yet
so click the link down below and upload
you before and after I want to actually
hear about your success story I want to
see your before and afters and every
week we do featured success stories so
click the link down below and share your
success